bonjour et bienvenue à bruxelles au
parlement européen pour ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo
dans cette émission nous nous rendrons
au rwanda nous avons suivi la balle
ambassadeurs de l'union européenne
nous verrons quel est son rôle at il un
rôle politique où l'europe est elle
finalement en afrique une super ong
mais d'abord un point sur la situation
au mali avec cette question où est
passée l'europe de la défense
vendredi 11 janvier à la demande de
bamako est sous mandat de l'onu la
france s'engage au mali pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
une guerre menée en solitaire les pays
européens soutiennent l'opération
discrètement et en ordre dispersé et sur
le terrain paris reçoit pour toute aide
quelques avions de transport
essentiellement britanniques de maigres
moyens logistiques pas d'opération
européenne coordonnée
la plupart des pays n'ont ni les
capacités militaires ni la volonté
politique de s'engager dans des
opérations de haute intensité seule
décision commune entériner à bruxelles
l'envoi d'une mission européenne pour
remettre sur pied l'armée malienne
la france fournira le gros des moyens
humains et militaires mais la mission
n'est pas encore prête et elle n'ira pas
au combat
les traités européens prévoient pourtant
la mise en place de groupements
tactiques 1500 hommes capables
d'intervenir vite dans une zone de
conflits hors du territoire européen
mais ces instruments militaires n'ont
jamais servi
alors où est l'europe de la défense
avec nous cette semaine une femme une
députée européenne qui vient du portugal
ana gomes bonjour bonjour en fait partie
du parti socialiste européen et vous
êtes spécialiste des questions de
défense que vous suivez depuis longtemps
alors les européens sont derrière la
france en tout cas ils soutiennent
l'intervention des seize mais mais mais
mais il n'y a pas grand monde sur le
terrain où sont passés où est passé lors
de la défense je crois que l'europe de
la défense est passé au même endroit où
est l'europe de la crise économique donc
la visitation
l'indécision le manque de leadership et
c'est pourquoi je salue l'initiative de
la france et de boue du président
françois hollande parce que ce qui est
en cause au mali s'est pas seulement le
la réponse à l'appel des autorités
maliennes
la réponse à l'appel du conseil de
sécurité des nations-unies qui avait
déjà passé deux résolutions là dessus
mais donc la protection du peuple malien
contre cette bande terroriste et
criminel mais c'est aussi la sécurité de
l'europe et donc l'europe devait être là
avec la france est par exemple un pays
comme le portugal dont vous venez est ce
que il est prêt à apporter sa
contribution sur le terrain oui un
premier ministre a été récemment à paris
avec françois hollande a dit qu'on
allait participer à la mission à cette
mission d'entraînement
de l'armée malienne que l'union
européenne doit déclencher et cette
mission elle était déjà dans le pipe
line donc alors qu'on doive a perdu
autant de temps parce que
malheureusement il y à quelques
partenaires européens qui pour eux qui
mettent des bâtons sur les rues les
rounds de 2 lesquelles par exemple la
grande bretagne en est c'est c'est un
paradoxe parce que d'un côté la grand
bretagne c'est un des pays les plus
forts comme la france en matière de
sécurité défense mais elle est là cette
attitude révoltante à l'égard de la
construction européenne et à l'égard de
la politique de sécurité défense en
particulier parce que ils sont encore
très attachés à cette question que c'est
une question de souveraineté nationale
mais quand il ya un problème de sécurité
qui a fait nous tous notre sécurité
bien sûr que non il n'y a pas un seul
pays
ni même la grande bretagne tout seul qui
puisse est allé tout seul qui est acquis
et les moyens militaires civiles parce
que c'est isation au mali bien sûr dans
le long terme ne peut pas se résoudre
justement avec des moyens militaires il
ya toute une des composantes politiques
très importantes où l'union européenne
sera un partenaire mais je dois vous
dire le des pays comme le mien
notre premier ministre dès qu'il a dit
que nous participerions côté de la
france à cette mission et par là dans
l'immédiat au combat c'est à dire dans
un deuxième temps pour former l'armée
malienne
oui bon tout d'abord et pour former
l'armée malienne mais même là avec des
restrictions qui sont celles qui
découlent de notre situation en ce
moment économique
alors justement vous pensez que cette
absence
de l'europe hier en libye qui a été
quand même une opération largement
franco britannique est aujourd'hui au
mali est ce que c'est dû à un manque de
moyens financiers
ou est-ce que c'est dû avant toi manque
de volonté politique et je crois que
c'est plutôt mains de volonté politique
bien sûr parce que les moyens financiers
sont là est une des solutions même si la
reprise
bien sûr une solution ce serait
justement d'avoir un financement commun
pour les opérations de la politique
commune de sécurité défense maintenant
vous savez il y à un fonds de deux
startups ont commencé qui et comment
mais tout le reste ce sont les pays qui
participent qui doivent aussi payer pour
leurs propres troupes
et bien sûr ça empêche que des pays par
exemple comme le mien qui ont des
troupes très bien préparés et très
capable d'opérer dans l'ems terrain
comme le mali que devait intervenir de
rim aurait regard venir aux mains
s'il y avait un soutien financier qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui parce qu'il n'a
pas de financement commun pour la
politique que pour les opérations pcs
des hawks classé 4e fallait changer et
de sécurité commune
vous avez dit que pourtant parlement
européen il ya eu des actions de fait
notamment l'an dernier ou même de
l'argent a été débloquée pour cette zone
du sahel considérés comme prioritaires
où est passé cet argent aujourd'hui à
quoi at il servi oui bien sûr on à
l'union européenne le jeu de lui même
avant l'opération de libye on a vu cette
montée de deux groupes bandes
criminelles liées au narcotrafic dans
toute la région de l'afrique de l'ouest
par exemple en guinée-bissau pays le
portugal connaît très bien
les autres criminels toutes sortes de
trafics dans la zone du mali se
chevauchant des réclamations de
mouvements qui sont tout à fait à temps
double qu'il fallait nous fallait pas
négliger comme celle du du mouvement de
malié touareg au mali l ena et et on a
vu tout ça et on l'a fait on a des
visées une même une stratégie de
sécurité sahel
donc on a mis en place par exemple une
mission pour le niger déjà pour
l'entraînement et on a vu on savait que
l'effet libye le lit la libye est un
énorme salaire marché d'arras mama et
les autorités maliennes ne peuvent pas
contrôler elles n'ont pas d'armé pour
pour intervenir ce sera notamment l'une
des missions de la future force
européenne merci beaucoup
ana gomes d'avoir participé à cette
émission on reste au mali actualité
numéro 1 en europe dans un instant
l'oeil du correspondant de bruxelles
juste après ce zapping des télés
l'européenne
la france visent désormais la reconquête
totale du mali avec ses déclarations du
ministre de la défense jean yves le
drian élargit davantage les objectifs de
l'armée française celle ci compte 2000
soldats présents sur le sol malien une
partie est déployé à l'aéroport de
sévaré à la frontière entre le nord et
le sud
sévaré représente un atout stratégique
pour lancer des missions vers le nord
occupé par les islanders outils web
français se sont engagés au mali mais
ils redoutent d'être entraînés dans une
guerre longue et difficile contre un
ennemi tenace mais que peuvent-ils faire
d'autre nous sommes ici pour mener notre
mission à terme
est ce que les forces françaises doivent
passer la main aux forces africaines
oui tout à fait des troupes africaines
venues des pays voisins comme le bénin
le ghana le burkina faso devrait
rejoindre les français un peu plus tard
sur le terrain mais pour le moment il
n'y a pas encore de soldats juste des
officiers supérieurs qui réunis dans
cette salle d'état-major tente
d'organiser leur arrivée l'union
européenne conduit une mission
d'information de l'armée malienne des
instructeurs polonais seront bientôt
envoyés sur place
c'est une décision que nous allons
prendre les prochaines semaines après
discussion avec nos partenaires travaux
in a world famille d'accueil n'est pas
gagné d'avancé difficile pour les
troupes françaises d'avancé en plein
désert passe onze islamistes
cette semaine nous accueillons nicolas
gros verheyde correspondant à bruxelles
pour ouest france bonjour bonjour vous
tenez également un blog très renseigné
sur la politique extérieure de l'union
européenne
alors faisons un petit point
opérationnel et notamment sur cette
fameuse mission européenne de formation
de l'armée malienne qui doit se mettre
en place
est ce que c'est pour demain ou pour
dans un an quel est le calendrier c'est
pas demain mais c'est pas dans un an le
calendrier c'est sincèrement accéléré
depuis l'intervention française
mais l'opération était déjà prête on a
avancé de gérer de quelques semaines
normalement d'ici le 10 février il ya
tout le processus de décision au niveau
européen sera fait céder roues aussi le
processus financiers parce qu'il faut un
peu d'argent l'opération va coûter 2
millions d'euros ce qu'on appelle le
financement commun et ensuite les les au
fur et à mesure des arrivées normalement
les formations pourront démarrer début
mars à vis à vis et relativement rapide
tous les pays européens vont participer
c'est ça la nouveauté qui a entre je
dirais avant-hier et demain c'est
quasiment tous les pays européens et les
polonais par exemple qui ont eu quelques
rêves les pays y compris les grecs
allaient sur la terre y compris les
grecs qui ont des problèmes financiers y
compris chypre il ya quasiment pour
l'instant moi j'ai fait un dernier
décompte il ya quasiment aucun pays qui
ne manque à l'appel
même des pays on n'a pas qualifiées très
enthousiaste sur ces opérations là comme
les tchèques donc tous les autres ont
plutôt des problèmes internes et pour
l'instant n'ont pas répondu mais ils
n'ont pas encore répondu non ils ont
fait 9 ça veut pas dire qu'ils vont tous
participé parce que tout dépendra des
moyens mais ça veut dire ce qu'il faut
voir c'est cette opération alors on peut
dire qu'elle est petite mais elle
s'appuie sur un élément qui a bien
marché qu'est la formation de l'armée
somalienne
ce que l'on oublie c'est que une des
réussites de la somalie c'est la
formation de cette armée somalienne qui
a été fait par les européens qu'est ce
qui ne peut avoir que peuvent apporter
les les européens dans ce type d'actions
dans ce type d'action sur la formation
il ya cette expérience là il peut c'est
pas une formation pour le plaisir c'est
une formation pour aller au combat
directement safer et sa force et effet
celle ci très bien on a l'exemple avec
les somaliens ça a bien marché et les
européens sont bien organisés çà peut
jamais démarré très vite chacun à des
spécialités faut pas croire y aller il
ya des armées européennes pour de trait
qui sont très petit mais qu'on très
forte spécialité par exemple sur le
déminage c'est tout aussi important sur
sur les
le sauvetage des vies sur l'appréhension
mais le combat urbain il ya tout
il n'y a pas que je dirais de trois
armées qui ont ces spécificités là vous
et que le tout est complet enfin chacun
peut compléter il suffit parfois de 2,3
de trois ministères bien formés bien
spécialistes sur ça pourra pour apporter
un apport et cette formation c'est un
peu le deuxième temps de l'intervention
française
alors c'est pas le premier temps mais si
on ne forme pas l'armée malienne dans
six mois
l'armée française est toujours là alors
qu'est ce que les européens auraient pu
faire de plus sur le terrain
je pense à -7 missile peut rêver
l'europe de ce qu'elle aurait pu faire
et il faut voir l'europe de ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
l'europe est en crise aujourd'hui donc
elle ne pouvait pas faire grand chose
mais on aurait pu penser qu'elle ait pu
avoir un cran supérieur notamment sur
l'aspect logistique
les européens ont fourni et fournissent
d'un peu de logistique c'est à dire des
avions du des moyens aux français on
aurait pu penser que c'était un peu plus
organiser un peu plus fort un peu plus
rapide il existe par exemple des
groupements tactiques est ce que ces
groupements tactiques peu peuvent servir
ces groupements tactiques aurait pu
servir pour différentes raisons
ils n'ont pas servi pour des raisons
politiques financières parce que engagé
un soldat ça coûte donc aujourd'hui le
problème et les il est autant financier
que politique et cesser battle group ils
sont restés à l'arrêt aujourd'hui le
battle group de permanence ces polonais
allemands et français c'est des grosses
capable d'intervenir c'est gros c'est en
alerte
c'est exactement exactement ce qui
arrive et l'armée française c'est
exactement le même cas mais avec des
taux européens avec des européens la a3
ce battle group et rester l'armé au pied
et à mon avis ce battle group restera
toujours l'art moquer parce qu'un
problème de concept donc il faut il faut
réexaminer le concept qu'il faut voir
comment l'europe peut agir
le problème c'est que l'europe a du mal
à agir de façon militaire elle a un
problème j'irai conceptuel là dessus en
même temps elle veut être une puissance
il faut qu'à un moment donné les
européens arbitre est ce qu'ils seront
une puissance sans l'armée où s pourront
rester une puissance en question
et vraiment politique merci beaucoup
nicolas gros verheyde pour cet éclairage
alors l'europe dispose du plus grand
service diplomatique au monde des
diplomates sont en poste en différentes
régions du globe mais que font-ils
françois beaudonnet va en parler avec
son invité véronique de kaiser mais
d'abord notre reportage
valérie brochard est allé seul avec sa
caméra au rwanda dans les pas de
l'ambassadeur de l'union européenne un
diplomate belge regarder son reportage
difficile de l'imaginer mais vous êtes à
kigali capitale du rwanda route flambant
neuf
électrification véhicules dernière
génération depuis le génocide de 1994
la communauté internationale aide le
pays à se développer
un homme déploie toute son énergie pour
la reconstruction du pays
il m'a dit qu'il avait rendez vous au
protocole
en début d'après midi mais il serait de
1,2 à l'ouverture chez dargaud et
ambassadeur de l'union européenne le 1er
janvier 2010 le traité de lisbonne a
créé le service européen d'action
extérieure qui rassemble 150
ambassadeurs de l'union envoyé en
mission un peu partout dans le monde
un bureau modeste une poignée de
collaborateurs
je dois être à au parlement j'ai une
petite aussi présentation droits de
l'homme au niveau logistique ne venez
pas rien d'ostentatoire michel arion et
au rwanda pour travailler et la première
de ces missions c'est de faire connaître
l'europe
il y en a qui ont des questions sur
l'europe sur l'histoire géographie
oui alors la question c'est est-ce qu'un
pays africain peut devenir membre de
l'union européenne
je vais vous répondre donc non il n'est
pas possible qu'un état africains
deviennent membres de l'union européenne
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'un africain
devrait devenir européen faisons l'union
africaine et ça c'est la réponse un donc
café café l'afrique
elle a créé voilà dans la soirée même
exercice mais avec un public bien moins
tendre dans une radio locale
mais chez la réunion défend l'europe et
sa politique extérieure a besoin de
classe puisque rappelle alors bonsoir
l'europe a reçu son prix de cause le
prix nobel
c'est assez exceptionnel d'abord comment
ce que ça va ça s'est passé de la ville
donc c'était d'abord il rentre une
surprise mais immédiatement je dirais
c'était quand même un sentiment de
fierté et de reconnaissance
alors ne pas été aussi pacifiste que ça
pendant des années parce que c'est aussi
que la période de la décolonisation sur
la période des guerres coloniales
représenter communiqué michel arion
seront disponibles pour les médias
rwandais comme pour les responsables
politiques de la région
mais il n'oublie jamais qu en tant qu
ambassadeur de l'union
il dispose d'une compétence exclusive le
commerce alors que les états membres
n'ont pas d'échangés commerciaux avec le
rwanda lui détient une enveloppe de 400
millions d'euros à répartir sur cinq ans
c'est une aide financière qui va
directement du fonds européen de
développement et du budget communautaire
vers le trésor rwandais compétence
exclusive qu'il manie avec diplomatie
puisque tous les mois portable tenu à
l'écart le chef de la délégation
européenne reçoit les ambassadeurs des
pays bas de belgique de france
d'allemagne d'angleterre et de suède
il a la mainmise sur les investissements
plus particulièrement concernant les
infrastructures du pays
donc moi on est déjà sur la route c'est
la route qu'on va faire oui mais elle
simplement on a commencé le chantier à
dix kilomètres pour pas créer du
désordre dans la sortie de la ville
l'union européenne a décidé de financer
cette portion de route qui est en fait
un des chaînons manquants sur ce qu'on
appelle le grand corridor nord de la
région de la communauté des états
d'afrique de l'est et donc il y aura une
le grand route de 7 mètres de large
matane a misé bitumée qui permettra donc
les échanges entre le congo le rwanda
l'ouganda le kenya et le reste du monde
à travers le port de mombasa
de combien alors nous on a financé ce
projet à hauteur d'environ 65 millions
d'euros
un peu moins d'un million d'euros le
kilomètre il investit l'argent de
l'europe mais toujours dans une démarche
sociale objectif employés un maximum de
rwandais et faire ainsi progresser le
niveau du pays
donc on a pris des options à haute
intensité de main d'oeuvre
on préfère faire de la maçonnerie plutôt
que du béton évidemment moi j'ai pas de
rêve pour le rwanda mon seul rêve c'est
que leurs rêves à eux se réalise le le
vrai enjeu pour les rondes essaie de se
réconcilier avec eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire
d'enfin
n'ont pas oublié le pardonner
toutes les questions liées au génocide
au niveau interne entre eux mais aussi
vis-à-vis du reste du monde
alors va pour ce reportage au rwanda
nous avons été rejoints sur ce plateau
par véronique de kaiser bonjour bonjour
vous êtes députée européenne vous êtes
vice présidente du groupe socialiste
ici au parlement européen et surtout
vous êtes une spécialiste je dirais des
affaires étrangères quand on voit ce
reportage
et quand on voit ce que fait
l'ambassadeur de l'union européenne au
rwanda on a un peu le sentiment qu'il
est finalement de représentant d'une ong
qui va faire le bien sur place mais on
se demande s'il est dans son rôle
d'ambassadeur qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
d'abord je pense que le reportage
reflète exactement ce que ce que font en
général les ambassadeurs dans ce genre
de région j'ai bien connu ce que faisait
l'ambassadeur en rdc c'est exactement ça
c'est à dire l'eau les infrastructures
des meilleures routes que celle que ne
font les chinois emploi de la population
locale etc
et donc c'est vrai jusqu'à un certain
point l'europe est le plus grand
donateur au niveau africain et on
pourrait dire nous sommes une super ong
est ce que c'est ça seulement la
politique étrangère de l'union c'est
toute la crise votre position se voit
mais écoutez pour le rwanda vous me
donnez donnez un exercice facile - le
rwanda
bonds est accusé aujourd'hui de soutenir
le m23 dans l'est du congo il ya eu en
2010 une série d'assassinats politiques
la politique de kagame est très
fortement critiqué certains pays
européens avaient même pris des
sanctions et l'entrée du bois n'a au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu a provoqué
un espèce de deux scandales donc il y a
matière à faire de la politique là bas
deux au visionnement l'europe m'en fais
pas enfin tout comme l'europe en
principe doit conditionner toute son
aide
une évolution d'un pays vers la
démocratie on lui demande pas d'être
démocratie vers une démocratie
est ce que la politique de kagame est
celle de camus l'a d'ailleurs est-ce que
ça va dans le bon sens c'est ce que
l'europe est ce que l'ambassadeur l'a
fait ça c'est pour moi rien n'est dit là
dedans mais oui mais vous qui connaissez
bien vous savez s'il ya des pressions ci
est ce que est ce que par exemple auront
envoyé une route là qui est en partie
financé par par l'union européenne est
ce que est ce que l'union européenne
devrait pas dire on arrête nos z
si vous n'allez pas dans le sens de la
démocratie quand ils les projets
concernent des infrastructures et de
l'eau par exemple arrêter les aides
c'est pénaliser la population mais il ya
des aides directes qui sont données
directs qui sont donnés aux budgets etc
et de toute façon il faut faire des
pressions mais je veux dire il faut le
dire il faut le faire et certains pays
l'ont fait certains pays européens l'ont
fait les pays bas l'ont fait et cédera
donc ils ont suspendu tant que part
activement on n'est pas obligé de faire
éternellement mais je veux simplement
parler politique et pas uniquement par
lé développement et l'innovation du
service d'action extérieure ça doit être
ça c'est à dire on ne fait plus
uniquement du développement vers les
pays africains ont fait de la job en
politique on fait de la politique
et là je ne vois pas ce reflet politique
contenue la loi du terroir quel premier
bilan dressez vous du service européen
d'action extérieure qui est dirigé par
madame ashton
on sait que c'était un jet à dire un
élément phare du traité de lisbonne qui
allait donner une visibilité de l'europe
avec sont donc son réseau d'ambassades
propres est ce que vous diriez on va
continuer dans les questions directes
est ce que ça marche parce que ça sert à
quelque chose
est ce que finalement ça ne coûte pas
beaucoup d'argent peut-être pour rien
coûté beaucoup d'argent durablement
il ya je vais je vais vous dire pour le
moment c'est pas c'est pas le top
c'est pas encore le top il faut il
distinguer probablement la personne de
cache-cache tonnes et le service
d'action extérieure alors il ya trois
éléments qui plaident pour l'indulgence
et on en a beaucoup discuté ici au
parlement
1 le service d'action extérieure a dû
être monté un service de 5000 personnes
montées en très peu de temps
qui n'a pas eu le temps d'avoir une
culture interne
c'est dur à faire de cathy ashton houle
a choisi telle qu'elle était une femme
qui n'était pas expérimenté dans ce
genre de travail
et là elle a pris mais eux
tout s'apprend pas aussi que ça donc
elle a eu à monter a servi de tentes
elle est reconnue comme une diplomate
efficace et la nouer d'excellentes
relations
mais de nouveau je reviens là dessus
parce que pour moi c'est capital
est ce qu'une diplomate c'est une
politique est ce que kate et ashley
d'une politique ou une super duflot mal
pour le moment ce qu'on lui
reconnaissait des qualités de diplomatie
et la ligne politique étrangère de
l'union européenne n'est pas encore
clair et la photo cathy ashton
est ce la faute des gouvernements et des
chefs de gouvernement qui n'entendent
pas du tout laissé une ligne politique
européenne sur lequel le consensus les
toujours difficile se dessiner en dehors
de sa vie la france l'angleterre vont
les grands pays l'allemagne ont envié de
mener leurs propres qualités d'être en
fait trop posé beaucoup de questions
mais vous donner une réponse vous dit
finalement s'il n'y a pas de direction
dans la diplomatie européenne c'est
parce qu'il ya pas de chef
ou en tout cas les chefs j'ai un petit
chef qui a été en plus inexpérimentés
trouver sa place et trouvé sa niche
je pense que là ya beaucoup à dire on va
changer de pays africains on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec l'invité précédent
parlons du mali est ce que vous pensez
que
l'europe est en train de jouer son rôle
aux côtés de la france dans le conflit
au mali où est ce que au contraire c'est
une occasion ratée
une occasion ratée peut-être pas mais
une occasion sur lesquels on a beaucoup
trop longtemps hésité je suis à
l'assemblée parlementaire afrique
caraïbes pacifique et j'ai rencontré
pendant plus d'un an maintenant mes
collègues du mallié dont certains sont
des chefs touaregs et il y a un an qui
tire la sonnette d'alarmé et qui depuis
l'intervention en libye ils nous disent
mais ils sont en train d'arriver
les ex de kadhafi chez nous avec des
armes et caetera et ils nous disaient
même mais vous devez les voir vous avez
vos satellites comment est ce que vous
ne les avez pas bloqués à la frontière
donc on a vu la progression
la déflagration de la libye se
répercuter vers le mali on a traîné et
puis on se retrouve l'europe à trèbes et
l'europe a dit on va envoyer une mission
pour soutenir l'armée l'armée malienne
donc soutenir une force
africaine et puis la mission et sa date
de du milieu de l'année dernière à milan
elle est toujours pas sur pied et donc
nous avons traîné
les rebelles ont progressé et avec les
rebelles
quand je dis les rebelles ce sont des
bandes criminelles qui vivent de trafic
d'armes de trafic de drogue de trafic
d'êtres humains
c'est pas des petits terroristes et les
grands qu'un russe de type al-qaïda et
on a maintenant de la semaine et
jusqu'au burkina faso une ceinture
terroristes qui est absolument goy
simple donc je comprends et on a soutenu
ici tout à fait la france
on dirait la maison mais l'europe a
traîné
parce que le processus de décision
européen est un processus qui reste
extrêmement merci véronique de kaiser
pour cette analyse merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation c'est la fin d'europe
hebdo on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine avec kathia gilder d'ici là
bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires